من الكرك الى حرثا ومضارب العبيدات وغيرها
من المدن والقرى الاردنيه وصولا ايضا الى
العاصمه عمان تستمر التحضيرات الاردنيه
للاحتفال او الاحتفاليه مع اقتراب الزفاف
الملكي لولي العهد الاردني الامير الحسين
بن عبد الله شهدت العاصمه عمان يوم امس
ليله حناء ملكيه لخطيبه الامير الاردنيه
المهندسه رجول سيف التي سبقتها عده
احتفالات وتجمعات حناء اردنيه شعبيه فرحا
بعرس الامير القريب جدا سيكون مشاهدينا
الاردن يوم الاول من يونيو حزيران المقبل
على موعد مع الزفاف الملكي التاريخي للولي
العهد الاردني الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
في قصر زهران بعمان الزميله سهى جميل كانت
من المدعوين وحضاره احتفال الحنه ليله امس
الحفل الذي اقيم في مضارب بني هاشم وارصدت
العديد من المشاهد التي
سننقلها وتنقلها هي لنا بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
البنات
والشعر عشان
مجنونه
ماديونات عشره صافا مثل
طيب قبل ما نروح الحناء هذه الليله اللي
تكون مميزه بالنسبه للعروس بالتاكيد
وكذلك يعني في بعض البلدان العربيه ايضا
الرجل يحطوله حناء بايده ويسكرون اذا
بالتالي هي هي عمليه احتفال تسبق بعض
البلدان الاعراس تيام الاحتفالات اسبوع في
اربعين يوم ايه
بس جميل جدا المحافظه على التراث وعلى هيك
موروثات ثقافيه جميله مثل ليله الحناء مع
انه ما ضل عن جد بستعمل الحنه يعني
بالطريقه اللي كانت تستخدم فيها زمان ولكن
لساتنا محافظين على هذه العادات والتقاليد
اللي بتعطي ثقافتنا وكل ثقافه مثلا في
الاردن في الكويت في السعوديه هذا الطابع
الخاص والمذاق الخاص جدا
هذه يعني ربما تكون خطوه الى انه تاهل
الزوجين الى هذه الحياه المشتركه ولكنها
ايضا خطوه للفرح بانه طريقهم مليء
بالسعاده اليوم احنا نقعد نتكلم عرس ملكي
في هذه المنطقه كيف سيكون الكثير من
الاسئله هذه الليله كيف كانت لانه خاصه
الجديد على الاقل في منطقتنا انه احنا
نشهد هكذا عرس والاجمل من هيك جميل كانت
موجوده في حفله الحناء وراح تخبرنا بعد
شوي شو اللي شافته وشو اللي صار لما نحكي
لما نعرف من شاهد على الحدث بكون مختلف
تماما غيره كمتلقي وكذلك كصحفي يشتغل
الصحفي اللي اللي داخلك بصراحه
مشاهدينا في حفل حنا ولي العهد الاردنيه
الاميره الحسين عبد الله وخطيبته المهندسه
رجوى سيف
ارتدت خطيبه الامير في ليله الحنه فستانا
صممته المصممه السعوديه العالميه هنيده
الصيرفي وتعد المصممه السعوديه هنيده احد
اشهر المصممين العرب والتي وصلت للعالميه
بعد تعيينها كاول سفينه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لعلامه شوبورد الشهيره
اليوم ستكون الصيف في ضيفتنا هنا للحديث
اكثر عن تصميمها لهذا الفستان فستان
الحناء لرجوه ال سيف خطيبه ولي العهد
الاردني
[موسيقى]
ايضا خليني بس نذكر بانه
التقاليد في الزواج المغربي ايضا برضو
خصوصيته وتفاصيل كتير
طبعا يعني شو هالاكيد احتفاليه كبيره
ومناسبه
عظيمه وانت طبعا كنت جزء من هذه المناسبه
بهذا التصميم الجميل لفستان ليله الحنه
احكي لنا اكثر عن هذا الفستان لانه شفنا
بعض التفاصيل بالصور كله مشغول يعني
باليد ايضا
صباح الخير والف الف مبروك للانسه رجوى
والاميره الحسين ربنا يتمم لهم بخير ان
شاء الله اكيد انا اشعر بكثير من السعاده
والفخر انه انا اكون جزء من هذا الحدث
التاريخي الجميل لكلنا بنشاركهم فيه من
السعوديه من الاردن واكيد برضو من العالم
العربي
الفستان كنت احكي فيه قصه
تتويج هذا الحب
وانقل فيه هويه
ادمج فيه الهويه ما بين الهويه السعوديه
والهويه الاردنيه من ناحيه الازياء
والثقافه اكيد كمان طبعا كنت حابه اوصل في
شخصيه الانسه رجوى الشخصيه اللطيفه
الحيويه الجميله اللي ساعدت بالتعرف عليها
من خلال هذا التعاون
وطبعا شاكر لهم لدعوتي لحضور حفل الحنه
اكيد طبعا حاولت انه انا استعمل اللي كان
معروف بالثوب النجدي الثوب السحابي وهو من
الازياء السعوديه
ومشهور بطول الكم حقه بحيث انه الكم يتحول
وهو يكون طرحه العروس
حرصت انه يكون في
النجمه اللي موجوده في العالم الاردني وهي
النجمه التي ترمز لسوره الفاتحه السبعه
المثاني اللي تحفظهم ان شاء الله وتحفظ
هذه الحب والزواج بحفظ سوره الفاتحه وكذلك
اخذت رمز النخله من السعوديه هذا الرمز
اللي يرمز الى عصب الحياه والحيويه والخير
والعطاء اللي في كثير برضه من شخصيه
الانسه رجوى
وكتبت شعر من شاعر التونسي
اراك فتحلو لدي الحياه حتلاقوا هذه
الكتابه برضو موجوده
طبعا
خليني خليني اعرف ما هي المواد ممكن يحكي
عن هذا الفستان
هناك ارتباط جغرافي بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والاردن لكن ايضا بودي ان اتساءل
ماذا عن المواد المستخدمه لصناعه هذا
الفستان مما هو مصنوع ولماذا يعني كان
بهذه الاختيارات
طيب اهم حاجه كان عنده ان انا احول هذا
التوب من انه يكون توب تراثي اطوره بحيث
انه هو يناسب شخصيه الانسه رجوى بتحاكي في
بنات جيلها استعملنا فيه طبعا الخيوط
الذهبيه
خيوط الحرير خيوط القصب والكنتيل هذه كلها
خيوط برضه مشهوره
في الاثواب النجديه طبعا برضه كان في
رسومات كثير من الرسومات
النباتيه والزخارف العربيه وكذلك برضه
الاشكال الهندسيه التي ترمز الى جبال
الاردن وجبال السعوديه كانت كلها عباره عن
فرح كلها عباره عن عن توصيل يعني هذا
الزواج المبارك ان شاء الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات